congressman
massey confronted merrick garland
about january 6th and specifically the
question about whether there were feds
in the crowd
deliberately instigating the crowd to
enter
the capitol building we know that this
is something that um
they'll the feds like to do
they like to encourage people to commit
crimes so that they can then prosecute
those crimes
and he played a video which i guess
we'll play this video first uh the video
features some guy um over the course of
you know more than a day down in dc like
in the night leading up to january 6 on
the the night of january 5th and then on
january 6th there's this one guy
who is all over the place trying to
convince the crowd to go into the
capitol
and you also know when we play this
video how does the crowd react
you know they're they don't want to but
this one guy is saying let's do it even
if we get arrested
um and there's a there's a theory online
i mean i don't know who this guy is but
the theory is among some people i think
a pretty credible one
is that this guy's a federal agent or an
asset um
this is the video that thomas matt that
congressman massey played for america
let's play the video first here it is
in fact tomorrow
i don't even like to say it because i'll
be arrested
we need
we need to go i'll say it all right we
need to go in
to the
tomorrow
we need to go into the capital
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
does speaking we go to the capitol the
capital is this direction
okay so you see there uh
one guy who has not been i don't think
he's been officially identified
but what we know is that he has not been
um
that guy who's on camera
all over the place saying let's go to
the capitol even if we get arrested like
acknowledging
that he knows it's a crime
trying to get the crowd to do it he
hasn't been arrested and charged with
anything yet
some of the other people in fact some of
the people in the crowd who were saying
no and calling him a fed they've been
arrested and charged but not him
what does that tell you well that was
the question that congressman massey had
for mayor garland let's listen to that
all right you have you have those images
there and they're captioned
they were from january 5th and january
6th
as far as we can determine the
individual who was saying he'll probably
go to jail he'll probably be arrested
but he wants every but they need to go
into the capitol the next day is then
the next day directing people to the
capitol and as far as we can find this
individual has not been charged with
anything you said this is one of the
most sweeping investigations in the
history
have you seen that video or
those frames from that video
so as i um
said at the outset uh one of the norms
of the justice department is to not
comment on impending investigations and
particularly not to comment about
particular scenes or particular
individuals this okay without i was
hoping today to give you an opportunity
to put to rest
the concerns that people have that there
were federal agents or assets of the
federal government present on january
5th and january 6th can you tell us
without talking about particular
incidents or particular videos how many
agents or assets of the federal
government were present on january 6
whether they agitated to go into the
capital and if any of them did
so i'm not going to violate this norm of
uh of of the rule of law i'm not going
to comment on an investigation that's
ongoing
so that's a yes um that's a yes because
if the answer was no if there were no
federal agents trying to rile the crowd
up rile the crowd up um then he would
have no problem saying no of course i
didn't have what are you talking about
there's no reason the i'm not going to
violate the rule of law the rule of law
says you can't
if there were no federal agents in that
crowd you the rule of law says you can't
tell us that
what law is that exactly
pretty clear pretty clear what happened
here um
you know a giant setup
and now they're arresting you know the
guy with the buffalo hat or the guy who
took uh
the the podium and walked out with it
every time i see merrick garland he is
the the you know if you were to look up
the term banality of evil in the
dictionary you would see merrick garland
this kind of
empty
dull
you know
just straight-faced emotionless person
nothing immediately uh objectionable
about them but then you listen to what
he's saying
and what he's doing
and it becomes clear and also by the way
congressman massey there
bringing up a very important point
getting the chance here to cross-examine
the the attorney general
congressman massey is
and you know how i feel about
politicians in general and about
republicans i'm not a big fan of
very many of them
[Music]
i'm pretty harsh on on all of them
it takes a lot for me to be impressed
by a politician but congressman massey
is one of the few good ones i don't
agree with him he's more he's more
libertarian than i am so i don't agree
with him on every single issue but
he's a talented and skilled
politician
um
and uh and uh a a
a real valuable defender of the
conservative cause
and someone who's actually trying to to
root out corruption
in dc
and putting his own career and
reputation on the line and doing so
he's a valuable one he's one we need
and he's also one and you might not want
to hear this but he's he's one
trump when he was in office tried to run
massey out of town
trump tried to get massey
out of office
because what did congressman massey do
wrong well he just he wasn't
person he didn't show enough personal
deference to donald trump as an
individual
and that's why trump hated massey and
wanted him gone
even though he's one of the best
republicans we have in congress one of
the few good ones trump wanted him out
because trump's
flaw as a leader his biggest flaw and
this is important to remember as we get
into 2024
his biggest flaw as a leader his fatal
flaw
is that for him when it comes to hiring
people and deciding who to elevate and
who to support the number one
qualification as far as trump is
concerned is is how they feel about him
personally
which means that a lot of really he
tried to run a lot of really talented
and valuable conservatives out of town
while hiring a lot of establishment
swamp snakes and rats because they
flattered him
as a fatal leadership flaw
i mean you have to be able to recognize
the talent and value of people even the
ones who don't personally like you that
much
you have to be able to set that aside
especially when we've got a country to
save here
something to keep in mind um
and that is a flaw that as far as we can
tell
ron desantis does not share
which is why it's desantis 2024 all the
way as far as i'm concerned listen hit
that subscribe button right now do it
right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated